[Musique]
en pleine partie de hand fauteuil
elle est belle c'est pas salé balle
l'équipe valls alone y découvre la
discipline apprentissage difficile pour
ces joueuses valides et quel que soit
leur niveau
susan va jock a évolué dans l'élite
nationale avec le fleury loiret handball
cette nouvelle approche de son sport est
un peu complexe
mazen m énerve ses zones moins chaud
qu'à
grande bosseuse d une qui marque tous
ses buts allen n'est pas capable de
mettre un seul but en tant que
en tant que handfauteuil passe à draveil
déjà plus les bras que sur les gens mais
du coup j'ai pas tellement l'habitude et
surtout il faut savoir aussi manipuler
le
le fauteuil roulant et du coup bah ouais
c'est c'est vraiment différent
les règles sont à peu de choses près les
mêmes les sensations elles sont toutes
autres pas de club en fauteuil à orléans
où habite aurélie elle a profité de ce
rassemblement régional pour intégrer
l'équipe de joué-lès-tours c'est des
supers sensations de glisse avec le
fauteuil les fauteuils sont très légers
très maniable c'est c'est super et puis
des sensations de sports collectifs à la
demande de ballons que je retrouve que
ça fait un bout de temps que j'avais pas
pratique et donc voilà c'est vraiment
des bonnes sensations du cardio aussi
c'est très très actif et très rapide le
hand fauteuil est ouvert à tous valides
et personnes en situation d'handicap
les équipes sont mixtes pour l'instant
il n'existe que deux clubs en région à
bourges depuis peu et à joué les tours
depuis 2010 joué-lès-tours club pionnier
en matière de hand fauteuil et en
adapter une section était ouverte aux
clubs en 2014
un bel exemple de hand ensemble